>> Sean: FOX NEWS ALERT,
DEVIN NUNES HAS FILED JUST
EARLIER TONIGHT MULTIMILLION
DOLLAR FEDERAL RACKETEERING
LAWSUIT AGAINST FUSION GPS.
THE CONGRESSMAN ALONG WITH
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER
JOINING ME NOW WITH MORE.
CONGRESSMAN LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS.
WE NOW KNOW THAT OR YOU ARE
ACCUSING THEM OF LITERALLY
WORKING WITH A CAMPAIGN FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY TO DERAIL YOUR
INVESTIGATION.
SECONDLY, ARE THERE ISSUES?
TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> WELL, THANKS, SEAN.
YOU'VE DONE A GREAT JOB COVERING
THIS THE LAST TWO AND A HALF
YEARS.
AS MANY PEOPLE KNOW, I WAS OFTEN
SMEARED.
AND NOW WHAT WE KNOW IS THERE IS
A LINK THOSE DOING THE SMEARING
AND FUSION GPS.
FUSION GPS HAS A LONG CAREER IN
THIS.
THEY HAVE A LONG RECORD IN THIS.
THEY WORK FOR THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT ALL A GUARD FOR THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO SMEAR BILL
BROWARD.
MOST PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THE
STEELE DOSSIER WORKING TO SMEAR
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WHEN WE WERE INVESTIGATING
FUSION GPS, THEY WERE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN WORKING TO SMEAR ME
TO OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
TO DERAIL OUR INVESTIGATION.
AND SO, I'M GOING TO HOLD THESE
GUYS OF ANIMAL AND THIS IS ONE
OF MANY STEPS TO TAKE BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO GO TO THE COURTS
JUST LIKE JAY SEKULOW WAS
SAYING, THE THIRD RANCH OF
GOVERNMENT WE HAVE TO RELY ON
THEM TO FIX A LOT OF THIS MESS.
>> Sean: WHAT DID YOU THINK
WHEN SPECIAL COUNSEL MUELLER
DIDN'T KNOW WHO FUSION GPS WAS
NOR DID HE NOTE JEANNIE RAY THAT
WORKED FOR CLINTON?
SARAH IS LAUGHING IN ONE WAY BUT
IT'S NOT FUNNY IN A BIG WAY.
>> REST.
BIGELOW, THE REASON WHY HE
DIDN'T KNOW, HE WASN'T ENGAGED
IN THIS INVESTIGATION THE WHOLE
TIME.
AND THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE
HAVE TO GO TO THE COURTS.
WE KNOW WE SPENT $40 MILLION
ROUGHLY INVESTIGATING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY, WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
SHOW FOR IT.
WE DON'T KNOW MANY OF THE
PLAYERS INVOLVED IN RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION AND FUSION GPS IS,
GIVE ME A BREAK.
THIS IS WHY THE COURTS HAVE TO
COME IN AND CLEAN THIS UP AND
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THIS HAVE
TO TAKE THESE CASES TO COURT SO
THAT WE CAN PULL OUT MORE
INFORMATION.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY, PEOPLE HAVE
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN RELY JUST
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OUT THERE OR
GROUPS WHO ARE OUT THERE NEED TO
TAKE THESE CASES INDIVIDUALLY TO
COURT.
>> Sean: SARA I SAW YOUR PIECE
TO DATE THE INVESTIGATIVE
HEARING, TOP OBAMA OFFICIALS
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT WITH WHAT
JAY SEKULOW IS SAYING ALONG WITH
COMEY WHO LIED, THERE IS NO
AMBIGUITY HERE.
HE VERIFIED THE DOSSIER WAS
TRUE, THE BULK OF INFORMATION TO
APPLY FOR THOSE FISA WARRANTS.
HE SIGNED OFF ON THEM THREE
TIMES IN THE INTERIM BETWEEN TWO
OF THEM, HE TOLD DONALD TRUMP IT
WAS NOT BARRETT VERIFIED AND
TRUMP WAS ACTUALLY BEING
INVESTIGATED WHEN HE KNEW BETTER
BECAUSE HE WAS LEADING THE
INVESTIGATION AND HE ALSO LIED
WHEN HE SAID HE WAS A SPY
BECAUSE THAT WARRANT ALLOW
SPYING.
>> RIGHT, WE NEED THE SENATE TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION
ALONGSIDE JOHN DURHAM IS DOING
RIGHT NOW, THE U.S. ATTORNEY AND
WILLIAM BARR, SEAN.
IT IS THE WAY THE ONLY THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WILL GET TO THE
TRUTH.
THE ONLY PLACE TO HAVE A HEARING
RIGHT NOW IS IN THE SENATE.
I MEAN SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
CAN HOLD A HEARING WITH THE
JUDICIARY, THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
IT IS POWERFUL AND HE CAN DO
THIS NOW.
WE CAN ALSO LOOK AT
CHUCK GRASSLEY,
SENATOR GRASSLEY.
AS FAR AS FUSION GPS IS
CONCERNED, SEAN, THEY ARE THE
EPICENTER, THE EPICENTER OF WHAT
I CALL A SOFT COUP ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
ABSOLUTELY WHAT DEVIN NUNES IS
DOING RIGHT NOW WHAT THE
CONGRESSMAN IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING BY SUING THEM.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GIVE US
INFORMATION.
THIS APPEARS TO BE THE ONLY WAY
IS BY SUING PEOPLE LIKE THIS IN
COURT AND COMPANIES, THIS
PRIVATE ENTITY WHICH WAS WORKING
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
WE KNOW THEY WERE CONNECTED AND
WE KNOW THEY WERE CONNECTED TO
THE RUSSIAN ATTORNEY, REMEMBER
THAT WENT TO GO MEET WITH
DON JR.
SO WE KNOW THAT ALL OF THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
AND OF COURSE,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT COMEY
ISN'T TELLING THE TRUTH, LIKE
YOU SAID, AS WELL AS
JOHN BRENNAN, JAMES CLAPPER,
SAMANTHA POWERS, --
>> Sean: SUSAN RICE.
>> SUSAN RICE.
>> Sean: AND BARACK OBAMA,
BARACK OBAMA.
>> THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Sean: THIS WOULD BE HIS
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
CONGRESSMAN, WE ARE EXPECTING A
PFIZER REPORT FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
TO ME COME ANYTHING SHORT OF
THESE WARRANTS WERE ILLEGALLY
OBTAINED, FREE MEDICAL FRAUD,
WARRANT, CHRONICLED IT AND
UNVERIFIABLE.
AND TO STAND BEHIND AT THE FBI
DETERMINED THEMSELVES IT WAS NOT
TRUE.
THAT WAS LONG AFTER THEY SIGNED
THE WARRANT.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AHEAD OF TIME.
BETWEEN THAT PFIZER REPORT,
PREMEDITATED AND THE DURHAM
REPORT, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL SEE JUSTICE UNDER
THE LAW AND EQUAL -- IMPLICATION
OF THE LAW?
DO THESE FIGURES THAT WE TALK
ABOUT FACE INDICTMENT AND
POSSIBLE CONVICTIONS?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW WE SENT OVER
CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
I WOULD FOCUS ON A CONSPIRACY
BECAUSE I THINK THAT IS THE LAW.
>> Sean: THE CONSPIRACY AND
THE CRIMINAL SENSE AND THE LEGAL
SENSE.
>> CONSPIRACY AND THE CRIMINAL
SENSE AND EXPECTED -- THEY
DEFRAUDED THE U.S. AND LIED TO
THE FISA COURT.
THEY HAVE USED CARTER PAGE AND
HIS RIGHTS.
THERE IS LOTS OF LAWS THAT WERE
BROKEN THAT CAN SIT UNDER
CONSPIRACY.
IT'S ABOUT PUTTING ALL THAT
TOGETHER IN A PACKAGE.
>> Sean: ALLIED AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, WERE
ALLIED AND INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
FIGHT IN AMERICA ON A
PRESIDENT-ELECT OR PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE?
>> OF COURSE, WE KNOW THAT.
THAT WAS THE WHOLE POINT OF US
PUTTING OUT THE INFORMATION WHEN
THEY WERE SPYING ON CARTER PAGE.
THAT WAS USED TO GO AFTER THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU, IT IS GOING
TO TAKE EVERYONE WORKING
TOGETHER IN THIS COME ALL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GET
TO THE TRUTH.
THIS IS WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT LAWSUITS ARE BROUGHT TO THE
COURTS, OKAY?
SO YOU SEE THAT WITH JUDICIAL
WATCH.
IT IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
IT IS WHAT JAY SEKULOW WAS
DOING.
ALL OF THIS HAD TO HAPPEN IN
ORDER TO PULL THIS INFORMATION
OUT BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW, THE
DEEP STATE IS VERY GOOD AT
HIDING THINGS.
AND SO IN ORDER TO GET AT IT YOU
HAVE TO WORK EVERY DAY TO PULL
BACK.
PIECES OF THIS ONION.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION
SARA CARTER COMMIT THE WARRANTS
ILLEGALLY OBTAINED AND THEY
OUTSOURCE SPYING ON AMERICANS
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
TRANSITION TO PRESIDENT, THEN
THE QUESTION IS, WHO'S GOING TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE HERE?
AND YOU KNOW, HERE IT WILL BE
DEVASTATING.
IF THOSE WARRANTS WERE ILLEGALLY
OBTAINED AND THEY WERE WARNED,
PREMEDITATED, LYING TO A FISA
COURT TO OBTAIN THOSE WARRANTS
AND THEN WE OUTSOURCE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN
LAW TO SPY ON AMERICAN CITIZENS,
YOU KNOW, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN, AS
HANNITY GOES TO JAIL OR ANY
AMERICAN CITIZEN GOES TO JAIL.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
ANYBODY WOULD GO TO JAIL, SEAN.
WHAT WE SEE AND I LIKE THE WORD
CONSPIRACY AND THE LEGAL SENSE
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS THE
NETWORK.
NOT OVER SPYING OVERSEAS BUT IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WHICH ACLJ IS
LOOKING INTO AN DEVIN NUNES IS
LOOKING INTO WHICH AS FUSION GPS
AND BEING AT THE EPICENTER OF
ALL OF THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
JOHN BRENNAN KNEW.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT HE
KNEW ABOUT THAT DOSSIER AND IF
HE LEAKED THAT DOSSIER TO THE
GANG OF EIGHT.
IN PARTICULAR.
AND HOW FAR THAT WENT.
BECAUSE ONCE WE KNOW THOSE
ANSWERS, WE WON'T KNOW WHO TO
INDICT AND WHO TO CHARGE.
I'M SURE THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
JOHN DURHAM IS DOING.
>> Sean: THANK YOU BOTH I
WOULD LIKE TO SEND AN